revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 y ya está de vuelta con
nosotros en el estudio Rosa Pérez mateu
Rosa bienvenida de nuevo aquí al
programa y vamos a abrir revista de
prensa con una noticia Pues que está en
todos los titulares de la prensa sobre
todo en Italia y qué pasó el arresto del
capo de la mafia la cosa nuestra traza
30 años de estar fugado de las
autoridades Rosa lo capturaron en un
hospital en Palermo cuando fue a recibir
tratamiento médico por un cáncer de
colon que le aqueja Rosa bienvenida
Gracias Raúl un placer estar de vuelta y
efectivamente no vamos a centrarnos en
esta noticia que encontramos tanto en la
prensa italiana como en la internacional
y empecemos por el medio de Guardian que
Define a Mateo messina de naro como el
último padrino no de las godfather el
supuesto capo de la cosa nostra y pues
esto no el último líder de la mafia
siciliana y uno de los criminales más
buscados del mundo además de Guardian
destaca que ha sido arrestado en Palermo
como bien decías tras 30 años ha de
estar dado a la fuga de Naruto tiene 60
años y estaba recibiendo supuestamente
un tratamiento contra un tumor en el
estómago bien ha sido detenido en una
operación que las autoridades han
calificado de bastante complicada
llevada a cabo por las fuerzas de
operaciones especiales del cuerpo de los
carabineros y te preguntarás Raúl Por
qué tan complicada esta operación si
este hombre tiene pues 60 años y estaba
en una clínica efectivamente bien pues
la razón principal es que no había fotos
recientes de su cara no las últimas
fotos que se tenían eran de los años 80
y de los 90 y las autoridades habían
reconstruido la que sería supuestamente
su aspecto a día de hoy a través de un
retrato robot sin embargo muchos
informantes de la policía no infiltrados
en amafia habían alertado de que había
pasado por cirugía estética y que por lo
tanto es su cara podría lucir distinta
de lo que se esperaría en un
envejecimiento natural y que además
había también modificado borrado sus
huellas dactilares y de hecho esto ha
conducido en que en las últimas décadas
decenas de personas hayan sido
confundidas por la policía y arrestadas
por error no pensando las autoridades
que estaban Pues deteniendo a denaro
bien en todo caso también de Guardian
señala no que era apodado diabólico o el
Flaco que continuó con el negocio
familiar de su padre que también era una
mafioso siciliano y que amplió no este
negocio a otros sectores empresariales
como el de la gestión de residuos o
también de los comercios de energía
entre otras cosas bien finalizamos este
este comentario sobre lo que dice el
británico de Guardian con el siguiente
párrafo dice según informantes y
Fiscales de la mafia él tiene la clave
de algunos de los crímenes más atroces
perpetrados por la mafia siciliana
incluidos los con bombas que mataron a
los legendarios magistrados antimafia
Giovanni falcone y paole borcelino en
2002 fue condenado inacencias sin estar
en el juicio a cadena perpetua por haber
matado ordenado el asesinato de decenas
de personas Qué dice Lemon de en Francia
Rosa Pues en este mismo sentido va con
esta frase tan amacabra no pronunciada
por Mateo messina de naro que es que
dijo que yo solo he llenado un
cementerio entero no y entre otras cosas
también señala como bien comentabas
antes como se felicitan las autoridades
italianas por este arresto histórico
vamos ahora sí con la prensa local la
prensa la prensa local italiana y vamos
a empezar con el corriere de la acera
Rosa Mateo messina de naro arrestado
después de 30 años prófugo Mejor vamos
con la República no pero empecemos por
el corriere precisamente Aunque quizás
no lo estamos pudiendo ver aquí pero
rápidamente este medio italiano nos
revela que
Ahí está dice que
usaba en esta clínica el nombre de bona
Fede De hecho no que no estaba inscrito
evidentemente con su nombre real sino
con este pues nombre falso y cuándo se
lo llevaron los carabineros fue entre
aplausos de los asistentes eh aplausos
hacia las autoridades entendemos no
Hacia El capo y por otro lado como
decíamos a que según las autoridades
estaba siendo pues tratado en fila de
espera para recibir tratamiento por un
tumor en el colon y siempre hay Raúl en
estas noticias no el típico comentario
de vecinos de personas que conocían
aunque fuera de pasada al finalmente la
persona detenida el típico de siempre
saludaba no me esperaba que esta persona
fuera a un criminal Pues en estacas en
este caso el comentario lo protagoniza
Estefanía filosto que es la jefa de la
clínica La Magdalena donde estaba
internado de naro que decía que nunca se
hubieran imaginado que ese señor
destartalado desaliña y despeinado en
fila de espera para ser tratado por
cáncer pudiera ser el Boss El capo En
búsqueda y captura desde hace 30 años
ahora sí vamos con la República rosa por
qué porque ellos hacen un artículo donde
destacan otros líderes también mafiosos
que siguen prófugos Exactamente no
porque desmienten un poco la épica de la
prensa internacional no que siempre nos
gusta pues dar una cierta pues
importancia no es que exactamente Pues
dice que bien si bien es muy importante
este arresto todavía quedan a cuatro Pro
prófugos relacionados con la mafia de
máxima peligrosidad no por un lado
atilio cubedu y Giovanni mozi
relacionados con anónimas ecuestre que
es una forma de los medios de referirse
a la mafia sarda por otro lado Renato
chin que granela de la camorra que es la
mafia napolitana recordemos pascuale
buena bota de landragueta que es la
mafia de calabria
vamos ahora con la estampa detalle
curioso de la operación del arresto de
enero Qué detalle Pues el detalle es una
cosa que queda como una incógnita no hay
que seguir a Sabiendo a lo largo de
estos próximos días y es saber por qué
de naro Finalmente no puso resistencia y
reveló su identidad cuando los
carabineros entraron en esta clínica no
dice la estampa cuando los carabineros
han entrado en las instalaciones el Boss
no ha puesto resistencia ante la demanda
de cómo te llamas admitido su identidad
respondiendo soy Mateo messina de Nano
claro Rosa y también esto Podría tener
que ver con que ella es una persona hace
60 años tiene cáncer de colon que es uno
de los cáncer más agresivos también que
existe en el tratamiento medicamento y
ya pues dirá Bueno me entrego y y me
hago el tratamiento y ya fue lo que fue
Pues sí vamos a ver
efectivamente sus declaraciones y ese
proceso ahora que empieza pues
teniéndolo a él esperando Que responda a
muchísimas preguntas que tendrán sin
duda los familiares de todas las
personas afectadas Pues por la mafia y
como y como sabemos Rosa mucho misterio
en estos arrestos de los grandes campos
de la mafia Gracias Rosa como siempre
por toda la información pasamos a
saludar a nuestro primer invitado el día
[Música]